[Musique]
bonjour à tous ce flash spécial pour
vous annoncer c'est très spectaculaire
explosion se serait un attentat selon
les médias américains à new york au
coeur de manhattan
en vous découvrez l'image en l'espace de
20 minutes deux avions ont percuté les
prestigieuses tours jumelles du world
trade center donc dans le quartier de
wall street en plein jour à 20h45 heure
américaine
les tours sont en feu vous l'avez vu pas
de bilan pour l'instant on parle de
plusieurs morts au moins et de dizaines
de blessés puisque à ce moment de la
journée
ces bureaux du quartier de wall street
sont déjà bien sûr occupé attentat selon
les télévisions américaines selon un
haut responsable américain également le
temps était très clair en voit mal
comment un accident aurait pu se
produire dans de telles conditions et
surtout surtout il y a cette suite c'est
deux avions qui donc en l'espace de 18
minutes exactement se sont encastrées en
quelque sorte dans ces deux tours
provoquant une explosion et un incendie
on va tout de suite revenir sur le film
des événements avec thierry curtet puis
on va évoquer bien entendu les premières
hypothèses se sont bien sûr ce sont bien
deux avions qui se sont abattues sur
chacune des deux tours du world trade
center de new york
ici sur cette image le deuxième appareil
qui vient percuter la deuxième tour les
twin sisters et deux tours jumelles
véritable monument historique de
manhattan sont le symbole de la toute
puissance financière et commerciale de
l'amérique
il semble que le premier appareil soit
un boeing 737 un avion commercial en
avion de ligne donc
et d'après les premières constatations
du fbi y aille l'avion n'a pas dévié de
sa trajectoire il semble bien qu'il se
soit délibérément jeté sur la tour et
ses 18 minutes plus tard qu'un autre
appareil est venu percuter lui aussi la
deuxième tour sur ces images filmées
depuis un hélicoptère
les deux tours sont en flammes il y
aurait eu d'après le fbi a eu une prise
d'otage quelques minutes auparavant sur
l'un des deux appareils
l' agence fédérale
était semble-t-il en liaison avec cet
avion la première explosion a eu lieu
vers 20h50 c'est à dire 14h45 heure de
paris ces deux immeubles abrite de
nombreux bureaux prestigieux et
stratégique de nombreuses
multinationales particulièrement
surveillés depuis un premier attentat
islamiste
en 1993